here's what would happen if our oceans  were made of gasoline  well since Earth's temperature is 16  degrees Celsius you'd see constantly  evaporating oceans of liquid gas not  every ocean would go up in Flames but  their surfaces certainly would burning  ocean surfaces would come with a major  toxic gas surge under all the carbon  dioxide carbon monoxide and nitrogen  oxides marine life would go extinct the  long-term gas exposure would give you  hallucinations Tremors and memory loss  and it would tank global trade since  gasoline has only 75 percent of water's  buoyancy ships wouldn't float properly  plus our fresh water would become  contaminated and we could expect acid  rainstorms in our weather forecasts gas  prices at your local pump would take a  nosedive but would it be worth the  respiratory illnesses